hey guys it's Gary and I've got fifty
seconds for you this is 50 seconds for
every 50 year-old in the world I need
you to understand something you have so
much time I'm an entrepreneur land and I
knew with all these kids show these kids
show these kids all these kids and and
they're taking advantage of the new
world right but they're young and Iran
I've got a lot of great and some of them
are great and they'll be all-time great
but what blows me away is how many of
you have decided that you're finished
that you're on the back end of your life
that you can't accomplish it that this
wasn't built for you I'm 41 years old I
didn't grow up with this [ __ ] either but
I figured it out you figured out how to
drive you figured out how to be a parent
you figured it all out and with the
health trends and the way the world is
now you got a long life in front of you
so instead of sitting in that job for
the next ten years go do your thing
you've got plenty and plenty of time